de moscou nous attend notre
correspondant jean didier revoir bonjour
jean didier quelles sont les réactions à
moscou après cette annonce faite ce
matin à l'aube à la télévision par
vladimir poutine intervention donc
armé spéciale en ukraine je crois qu'on
peut dire qu'elle a cette annonce a pris
à toute la population un peu de court en
annonçant sous peu deux russes
s'attendait à ce que les opérations
allaient aussi vite on range ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que depuis lundi et la
reconnaissance par réduire routine des
républiques autoproclamées de donner ce
que de lougansk est bien l'idée d'une
unv conflit avec l'ukraine faisait petit
à petit son chemin dans la tête des
russes un sondage qui datent de samedi
opéré par l'institut vite sur ce qui est
relativement fiable
affirmé que 73 % des russes soutenait
cette reconnaissance opérée par vladimir
poutine que 50 % des russes estimaient
que moscou était tout à fait en droit
d'empêcher l'ukraine de rejoindre l'otan
ils n'étaient que 43 % à être contre une
utilisation de la force pour annexer
l'ukraine à la russie alors on voit le
pignon russe est relativement été
relativement favorables à l'idée d'une
opération
reste maintenant à voir comment est ce
que cette population va réagir le face à
un véritable conflit avec des morts des
blessés des victimes pour l'instant les
télévisions russes repassent
régulièrement des morceaux de
l'invention de vladimir poutine de ce
matin et puis plutôt que de montrer les
bombardements en ukraine c'est surtout
sur ce qui se passe dans le don de basse
que les télévisions s'attarde elle nous
montre des images de bombardements qui
ont lieu dans le dos de basse des
reporters qui
témoigne sous les bombes des exactions
attribuées imputées aux forces armées
ukrainiennes et pour l'instant la
population se fait petit à petit à
l'idée d'un conflit avec l'ukraine reste
à savoir dans quelle mesure elle sera
d'accord de le soutenir à partir du
moment où il ya des morts des victimes
qu'on va pouvoir commencer à décompter
malheureusement tous les jours des
cercueils qui reviennent en russie
effectivement jean-didier rejoint
la russie a
préparé j'ai envie de dire ses
concitoyens à cette intervention avec
toute une propagande en parlant même
d'un génocide dans l'est de l'ukraine
les télévisions d'état participent à ce
discours du chef du kremlin ah oui
effectivement elle relaie elle relaie le
message est là la vision du kremlin la
presse libre n'existe quasiment plus ici
en russie 1 toutes les poules et tous
les grands titres sont détenus via des
participations par des oligarques où des
gens proches du régime les rares médias
indépendants
ont été sommés de fermer parce qu'ils
étaient accusés affublé du fameux statut
d'agent de l'étranger un statut qui
posait des problèmes qui leur posaient
des problèmes pour trouver des
annonceurs une fois qu'ils étaient
affublés de ce statut vient beaucoup
d'annonceurs ont fini par retirer les
publicités qui le mettait dans ses
médias contraignant ces médias
malheureusement a fermé et donc
effectivement le les voies seuls des
voix discordantes qui pourrait qu'ils
s'expriment contre cette intervention le
sont via les réseaux sociaux à travers
certains hommes certains experts
certains politologues certains blogueurs
mêmes qui ont relativement de succès en
russie qui appelle la population à ne
pas soutenir les autorités dans leur
dans la guerre entreprise contre
l'ukraine merci beaucoup jean-didier
rejoint d'avoir été en